one of the top quarterbacks in the game
today in his fifth year now entering his
sixth year in the National Football
League out of UCF good to see you AJ boy
hey how are you I'm good how are you I'm
good
so just for all of my colleagues in the
in the NFL media can you say your name
because I think it's the most
mispronounced name in the National
Football League boy yeah boy yes sir
what's the worst spot a botching you've
heard of um Booya
Bowie we boogy boogy boogy boogy exactly
I don't know where they got that from I
don't know why was sounded like a.j okay
AJ AJ Booya I've heard that one that's a
good one so AJ Bowie of the Jacksonville
Jaguars you've heard jagwire too right
you've heard that jagwire yeah yeah it's
okay there's no W that kind of from okay
so AJ boy here on the Rich Eisen show I
loved watching you guys play football I
loved it how would you describe
Jacksonville Jaguars football we got a
lot of grit you know Coach Coughlin
coach Monroe and they always talked
about it just grit especially in the
backend and on defense we have a lot of
playmakers and one day we try to do we
try to put on the show especially for
the fans towards the end of the season
especially in a playoff game against
Buffalo we had a sold-out game they
removed the tarps and the energy was
just amazing and that's one thing that
we definitely want to get going and
going into next year and then we got
more weapons we just got a guard
montcrief I played against them for the
past four years he's he's definitely
slept on so I'm definitely looking
forward to the future it's interesting
now I'm truly not trying to stir
anything up but the first coach his name
you mentioned was Coughlin and so much
of what we talk about in the national
media about Jacksonville is you guys
weren't making your run was talking
about how Coughlin had changed things
coming in what what did he change that's
G I know that's why I say I came in you
came yeah so it was a little different
but they just said that the way they
approached it it was the main message
that Coughlin told me when I first
signed there was just showing these guys
you know
to be a pro and you know I believe that
we did that as far as me berry church
and definitely Kaleo Scalia's had a big
part to do with it he's a vet in the
game the way he approached it same I
said every day and you could just see it
starting to rub off on all the younger
guys and the approach that we had we was
looking forward to the condition and we
was looking forward to competing against
each other whether also Ted became in
practice against us we was just always
trying to find ways to get better wait
room meeting rooms even all to fill
outside of Stadium so just bring that
approach starting camp really in OTAs
and you just helped us a lot in just to
see how far we went and how hard it took
to get there you know we're looking
forward to this all season and getting
back together and how much was confident
around how much contact you have them um
he's everywhere but he doesn't talk but
you know he's there you know exactly
where he's gonna sit what do you mean
when we go on a team in room he's right
there hitting us on the lay like there
we go
pay attention all that we just knew he
was there but he wasn't saying much
coach Marah was communicating everything
and he's done a great job with us he
kept everybody together and we just
stayed you know it's like a tight-knit
group and it was just starting to show
throughout the season so meet it what
time was your meeting
no our mean was I'll say towards the
middle of season and starting at 7:30 8
o'clock but we had to be there five
minutes earlier but so you so meeting
7:30 you had a walk in at 7:25 yeah but
here's the thing and it was different
cuz I went to I went to UCF and I had
Coach O'Leary so him and Coach O'Leary
were closed okay Coach O'Leary say be be
there 15 minutes early but what Coach
Coughlin to do he'll move the clocks
back so he'll move them five minutes
back in everything like that so only
time that they was the actual time was
during game days when he was at the
stadium so we didn't know if we still
had to be there five minutes early or
not and we're just rushing running and
we're on time but we're not on time and
we're not trying to get a fine so well
I'll share with you one of my favorite
stories of having worked at the NFL
Network since its inception in 2003 and
easily one of the most awkward moments
I've ever had
off camera was I was at a and owners
meeting
in Hawaii okay time my shows done all
done if his off time right in the middle
of the afternoon and I'm getting a
massage gonna get ready for a massage
you know
I'm gonna treat myself and there I am in
the spa waiting room you know with the
music and the bonsai tree and the the
fountains and all that business and the
the you know GQ magazine's I'm thumbing
through who's coming in for his massage
in a terry cloth bathrobe tom coughlin
it's just me and tom sitting in this
meet and waiting room and i'm gonna take
tom how our coach how are you rich
nothing we don't say anything and he
goes so what time's your massage and I'm
like well it's coming up in about five
minutes he looks at the clock he goes
he's like right now I could go to the
desk right now and find out where this
person or masseur was not on confident
time I just wish there was somebody else
and and I felt bad for whoever was at
the spa front desk
I mean people people think he's a I'm
not gonna say he is a hard-nosed guy and
everything but the more you know what he
does especially for the city with his
foundation and everything you have a lot
of respect for him he's got a big heart
definitely he really does so who ate
well how do i reset AJ AJ booboo ji of
the Jacksonville Jaguars yes or just
we'll just call you by your real name AJ
boy of the Jacksonville Jaguars here on
the Rich Eisen show let's get into this
now here because everybody looks at what
you did in what you did this year and
says essentially you can't do it again
because of your quarterback how do you
respond to that that's for them you know
we're tuning out the noise that's one
thing that we did last year especially
the route that I took from an individual
standpoint I was undrafted a lot of
people said I wasn't going to be in
alley long you know every player looks
in this stuff like that the criticism
and everything like that and we use it
as motivation so for people to say that
we love to prove them wrong it's just
I'm extra motivation that's gonna get us
to where we want to get to I mean how he
was just you know extend
resigned or however you want to put it
it was labeled by many as a mistake by
the way not here
ii-i've called Blake bortles the maker
of Stars and remover of tarps first of
his name and house bortles Blake bortles
and so how how do you feel about him in
that locker room um you know he's he's
starting to be a probe I was talking to
him towards the end of the season you
know about some books I was reading you
know we went to college together so I'm
definitely rooting for him and I want to
say Buffalo even in the playoffs
especially against the Steelers and the
Patriots he carried his weight against
the two best quarterbacks in the AFC and
when you see that that's that's you know
great things for the future and then
from an individual standpoint I never
try to put the defense on it but from my
standpoint I have to do a better job of
finishing just not to put him in that
situation so I'm excited you know he has
he has a strong arm he could run he's
athletic he's gonna be healthy coming
into it and we're definitely looking
forward to it
well there's two things that I just
picked up on right there that you said
but I just want to hit a couple and you
said starting to be a pro what can you
let me in on that and everybody in on
that what do you mean by starting to be
a pro he was you know when I was I was
playing against him you can see his body
language in the way he was acting
especially the year the quote/unquote
bad year that he had but you know ever
since I came and I signed he was he was
in the training room doing the same
movement prep everything like that
making sure that his body was right he
was taking care of himself
watching extra film he was with Chad
Henne they was talking football and then
you could just see everything he
everything he was doing he wanted the
win he wanted to be the best player you
can for the team and you know our Jim
Caldwell did a great job you know
bringing me Barry
Collison and the other guy so we know he
made the right decision when it came to
getting Blake and you see why the team
always had his back because he started
to show especially in a playoffs what
he's capable of and when you said books
that you wanted to share with him walk
me through that which books uh it was
called relentless it's one of us I read
every offseason just from my standpoint
and it's a great book in what do you
like about what why do you think it
might have been pertinent for for him to
read that well because you know you
always going to have
that's gonna doubt you but she can't you
can't pay attention now you just got
focused on a positive and just always
stay relentless no matter what happens
you can't just stay down you gotta keep
pushing in you know sometimes we had
that dark side and it's but we use it as
motivation so one practice we was
warming up and Blake was like darkside
baby and I was like yeah you've been
reading it so okay you know he I'm proud
of bleh he deserves everything he got
and I'm just looking forward to the
future with him and it's written by
Jalen Ramsay is it Jalen straight
sayings of straight facts you tell me
the new book by Jalen Ramsay he's gonna
he's gonna join us later on this week
called f off I love that guy it was
great yes
he sat right behind us in NFL honors and
I died you need and I was just talking
about it earlier in the show with the
Jets with Jamal Adams you need to have
somebody in the locker room who talks
and walks the walk and you pick up what
they are putting down and you need to
match the intensity and I want somebody
in my locker room for for whom football
means so much you could see it you could
see it you could feel it you could and
you know obviously some I was just
joking in that regard he does need to in
a way just turn it down from 12 to 11
before he gets it down to 10 and away I
mean you ever thought that he probably
used that on purpose though it just
makes them play that much better and
it's working exactly so and I said it
before you know the things that he say a
lot of us want to say but he has a
platform he's a person that does it and
we always have his back no matter what
and you know it just it just showed you
type of person he is he hates to lose he
wants to win and you never want to let
him down and I could say no matter what
goes on between teammates and a locker
and everything one thing that we don't
want to do is let each other down and it
shows it does I want to talk a little
bit more with AJ boy here of the
Jacksonville Jaguars it is how many
seconds left and that one there Barak
Wood is 69 67 Rhode Island by two right
55 seconds left Rhode Island up to and
the Penn Quakers have a five-point lead
on Kansas with seven minutes into the
game
it must be March Kansas is choking oh
stop it come on man and play in the Ivy
League which they slow it down and they
are they are they are efficient
fundamentally sound Kansas : I don't
even want to know
I have a movie date you have a bracket
okay he can we can propel I am pulling
for college section though okay and I
was I mean ain't over yet but no they
may give a tray a hard time so all right
I know I definitely I know that so I
wanna also want to hit you know you
you've got basketball and your family
brockman do you know who this guy's
cousin is you root for him every single
damn time of the Celtics take the floor
that's coming up next with AJ boy of the
Jacksonville Jaguars here on the Rich
Eisen show
AJ boy of the Jacksonville Jaguars
another segment with Yuka to this that
guy appreciate you sticking around this
up update from our poll question brought
to you by Farmers Insurance when you're
dealing with life's up and downs it
helps to know the ins and outs of
insurance let farmers share with you
practical knowledge game from more than
90 years of experience we know a thing
or two because we've seen a thing or two
find an agent if farmers calm give us
the poll question results as they stand
right now middle of our number three
guys what's the best sports weekend of
the year we'll start at the bottom nine
percent Cinco DeMayo weekend I'm shocked
this is not winning NBA NHL playoffs big
fight weekend and Kentucky Derby how
does that only have 9% 21% March Madness
opening rounds this weekend we got right
now 22% masters weekend and MLB opening
day and 49% football is king boys and I
felt divisional round weekend what would
you say to that answer I'll say just for
the simple fact you know even if you're
not playing in it oh remove yourself
from the playing put yourself on a couch
I'm not gonna lie uh what was it my
rookie year when they had the divisional
round it's just you know every game is
gonna be aired the whole world's
watching so you know primetime you put
on the show and that's one thing that we
was looking forward to this year you
know we didn't have any primetime game
night time games or anything so this was
our opportunity to show where we were as
a team especially against Buffalo and we
it was packed you knew it was just time
to go you knew everybody was watching
and you know our game just rose that
much better
AJ boy here in the Rich Eisen show how
come you had the Steelers number what do
you think she's something I'm filmed
about Big Ben that you guys were able to
pick up man I've been before I even saw
him with Jacksonville like I try to
watch film especially on my cell but
like all the top corners and I just
watched who they matched up against and
you know a lot of people was having
problems with a B and you just it came
to conclusion with me it was like you
got a score him but you got to play good
defense you got to just create turnovers
and that's what we did because at the
end of day they're gonna put up points
they was putting up points even though
we had a big lead the first time we
played them but the second game it was
we had a big lead but I think been
through for like 500 yards
so we still was fortunate enough for you
know our office to put up a lot of
points but that's type of game that
you're gonna have with Pittsburgh it's a
shootout they're always gonna put up
points with all the weapons they had but
you just gotta capitalize and that's one
thing we did we capitalized on the
turnovers yeah I'm and Leonard fournette
just seemed to have a day what what what
you pick up from him when you first met
him Leonard fournette he wants to be
great
you could tell so what happened with
picture day I thought he was excused I
thought he was excused but I don't know
exactly what happened I didn't even
first noticed that he missed it but he
couldn't play that weekend and you think
he learned for something from that oh
definitely um everything that Leonard
does it's not he's not a me guy it's not
always about him you you see that he
does a lot of things for the o-line for
his teammates and he just jokes around a
locker room a lot when it just be like
me him Jalen and TJ yelled and he's a
good guy and that's one thing about our
team like you could really see that we
have good character people in our team
mm-hmm and let's get to the AFC
Championship game why are you shaking
your head man I've been when I'm
training that's all I think about I
never try to put blame on anybody or
anything and I just try to focus on what
I could do better I've been watching
films especially or that second half see
how could I put myself in a better
position even with whatever we were
playing or even on the place that I had
and when you when you go to the Pro Bowl
when somebody don't really know who you
are and all they want to tell you is man
that wasn't a flat that's the first
thing that's that's what I'm being known
for not known for the great numbers I
put up this year two six interceptions
all this I'm known for the guy who had a
DSP I call and I'm not taking none away
from the refs you got to see it from
their point of view but it was a tough
game and we were that close
now you're referring to the end of the
first half yeah definitely on that play
but Brandon cooks yeah but just in
general even we had the lead they
started with the coverage we was running
there was times I could have played more
aggressive even while I was off and I
was just trying to protect over top
because I had to read 1 & 2 but
when you watch the film especially me
and I was just gratine I was like man I
could have done this better and I
started working on that while I'm
training and I got back to it right
after the Pro Bowl like when you're that
close you know how hard it is to get
there you just you get that much hungry
and that's why I'm kind of it was a
setback but I'm definitely looking
forward to playing them this year
competition committee age a boy egg of
the Jacksonville Jaguars by supposedly
considering making a defensive pass
interference a 15-yard penalty like back
in your day at UCF would you be for that
I don't have a problem at the end of the
day you can see that you know if
somebody's getting beat and they hold
them now it's like 15-yard penalty but
at the end of the day I look at it like
that's just more opportunities for us at
CBS and make plays I didn't have a
problem the way it was now it just means
you got to be that much better with your
technique but you know they they're
starting to see that you know it's not
just about offense we have some ballers
on the defense all throughout the league
and we're just trying to make plays how
would it change how if they make DPI
defensive pass interference 15 yards as
opposed to spot foul how I think I think
they'll start calling more more flags
though just because they know it's gonna
be 15 yards because when the corners
beat they're probably gonna look to grab
now like even if they're be they're just
reaching out to slow them down so at the
end of the day that's always the model
with a DB if you beat especially at
college it was if he beat grab them just
don't let him pass you I mean we not
we're not trying to give up points
that's the object of a football you know
you know put up points defense make sure
we don't put him up what do you think of
the catch rule as it currently stands
that's that's tough man for the simple
fact um
when Earth's caught that touchdown in
the Super Bowl and was it Collinsworth
he kept saying like that shouldn't be a
catch I'm like he ran on his own he fell
he wrote he doe for it but then
everybody's trying to compare to the
Jesse James one in Pittsburgh and I felt
it was little if he either way it went
in you can't make anybody happy
there's one person that's roof we're
just seen there's one person who for
that team either way go somebody's gonna
say it's not a catch so I thought the
Ertz catch was a catch because I was in
the stadium I did not hear the broadcast
okay I thought Jesse James is a catch
too and should because he had won me
down and was able to turn his torso over
the end zone and he broke the plane he
should have been a runner than
that his on the ground and he wasn't
touched I felt like yeah just because he
reached out it should have been called
like as far as I touched now cuz he
reached out to break the plane and
you're fine as a cornerback in this
league if that would be the rule yeah
because at the end of the day we we try
to play the ball to the ground but we
understand certain situations if you
break the plane before you hit the
ground that's understandable and then
that always goes back to the Dez Bryant
catch he called it
stumble and you could tell that he was
trying to reach out for the pylon and it
fell in that's where all this got
started I believe really ordered Calvin
Johnson Calvin
that's great it's tough and we asked a
lot you know especially as fans and
everything we asked a lot of the refs
and even players but you got a look at
it from full from their view and now
that we had the replay to see everything
gets a little bit tougher but it's tough
either way it go as tough calls but you
got to live with them and just play the
next down a couple more minutes with you
AJ boy of the Jacksonville Jaguars you
said you went to you know you were
teammates at UCF with Blake bortles
mhm I don't know how tighten in a group
you all aren't you know UCF alums but do
you know the Griffin kids yeah crazy
thing I was training when I went by the
UCF before the starter last year and we
was over here talking trash we should
kill talking trash when she came over
here trying to say who had the better
DBS while we was there and I knew what
Shekinah was capable of I know what his
brother she killed did I knew I had a I
thought he was gonna run a four four but
just for him to run that for three it
just shows you know those are track guys
and he's a hungry guy and we could learn
a lot from him he's not letting what
happened with his hand hold him back so
what do you what do you think he could
do in the end of home he could do great
things
not only on special teams but definitely
on defense he's a ball or one thing
about it I felt like UCF has always been
slept on we've we be in Baylor when
Blake was there
they beat Auburn we beat big teams when
I was there we'd be UGA and I guess we
just never considered a big school but
never consider small school we never get
the respect but he's gonna do some great
things and Ali I'm definitely looking
forward to seeing sure came and playing
against him and Richard Sherman said if
he's not drafted in the first two days
first three
the system's broken would you agree with
that well we're not gonna talk about how
to system broken because he's gonna get
drafted first a second day so we don't
have to worry about that but that's just
really Richard letting him know that
this guy can play and when you cut on
the film and see what he did especially
against Auburn you know he can play all
right last one for you tell that Boston
Celtic fan where your cousin is Oh
jaylen Brown Kevin Brown yeah I know
that's his brother over there Quinn so a
question so this year there's a hard
sorry there's he stirred it up those
saying he was rooting for you guys
there's a Kyrie the playoffs it there's
a Kyrie so that that teams going all the
way I'ma be there to do will be huh okay
yeah I guess there's no NBA team in
Jacksonville but there's definitely a
football team was all stirring it up
exactly so what's your game like as well
as oops oops man I was
I played point you know I had a little
bit of a jump shot I ain't shooting the
three toe but my dad always had me
playing defense I was more focused on
defense because it was gonna help me
with football cuz I knew I was gonna
play corner no I just play basketball
cuz I loved it but my main my first love
was baseball
so who's the best basketball player on
the jaguars well jaylen Rams you say he
is of course he's gonna say yes but it's
all he does is driving don't that's
that's it I mean I mean it's a pretty
good score you play LA Fitness I mean
that's all you need I try to see I have
a hoot I have a hood with everybody
I heard Gibson got a good game I like
guys who got like an all-around game
like they utility no ball
hey when a dunks worth three points
that's when I start doing it nice good
Hey great meeting you I've really like I
said I've enjoyed watching you from afar
and your teammates good luck to you
don't be stranger anytime you're in LA
let's let's chat throughout the season
but Ryan would you you never told me
where you trained for I don't know I did
my wife says I and that guy over there
Brockman says I should just buckle down
folk Kenny Stills told me he wants to
frame me and that I need to do it for
months before I run stark oh we gonna
get you in the fire that would be good
by the way
AJ great to see you
thank you bet AJ boy a here on the Rich
Eisen show the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience